bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono famiglie sono
totalmente attratto dalla maglia rosa di
share
quanto sei figo zio 6 ragazzi su dos
film new york cao fei che sarebbe in
italiano non versare il tuo caffè o
ragazzi play come ci si muove a così
ubriaco ma cosa fa a azie
no non credo che questo sia il modo
migliore per bere un caffè alzati a non
ci si può alzare quando capì sei morto e
capire cosa sul culo sto tizio che non
si capiva come beve ma questo ubriaco lo
zio ascoltami
vai dritto per l'amor di dio vai dritto
ma mentre ma che cazzo fai notte ubriaco
piano di prima mattina sembri che case
infatti è bevuto vodka tutta la notte
bravo bravo bravo ci credo
devo accendere con sensore fermi e non
dietro dietro dietro dietro alzati dai
uomo forza ma cosa fa presidenza
va bene basta c'è anche una parte dietro
posso andare indietro no no no scherza
lo schiacciava scherzavo e va beh
qualcosa che ho sulla chiappa a destra
che non credo sia per bellezza c'è prima
devo passare prima davanti al suo
sensore giusto girarmi successo no
girati girati uomo no fan a fan culo o
solo 30 secondi per entrare nella porta
dai che ce la fai zio dai che ce la fai
ce l'ho fatta ce l'ho fatta
se certo fatta scommesso un'ora e mezza
la pasta che cosa fa dai ragazzi primo
livello finito poi chissà chi l'ha
assunto sto tizio va infrante stavolta
ci siamo più carichi di prima più carica
non hanno spostato il sensore hanno
spostato anche il mio cervello non lo so
dimenticato a casa
jia jia jia yi e poi che non puoi usare
l'altra mano e si muovo monco dai fatti
ma cosa cazzo fai e va bene va bene non
è chiusa la decima in causa però c'è il
riflesso cioè un gioco di merda brucia
riflesso nel vetro non ce l'ha così
nessun gioco riflessione in vetro e
sicura me comunque sto caffè ragazzi c'è
della vodka mischiata del gene mischiato
a del rum piano piano ho mica un anno e
mezzo però c'è adesso ce l'ho fatta in
un nanosecondo ci ha messo una vita aver
fa sta cosa nuovi horvath tipi un loft
stick
oddio magari ma vuol dire che posso
muovere il mio culo anche da in piedi
mica al gioco dell'anno rega che cazzo
sta facendo che ho scoperto di poter
muovere il culo gioco dell'anno
veramente uncharted please che piano
piano vogliono sta facendo
sono caduto dai frate dai frati che ho
capito il meccanismo trovata come sta
camminando regale cos'è sta roba
vai vai vai vai così entra così alla
riunione entra così ti prego ce l'ho
fatta se è arrivata in ritardo al tuo
meeting e ai anche dimenticato quale
fosse l'argomento ma non credo che sto
tizio sia capace di intrattenere con
argomenti credi in verticali challenge
devo alzare il culo oppure no da bravo
su qualcun etto socio palco letto come
fa la mamma
la cosa sta facendo coi piedi no che
verso il caffè e vabbè ma non ci arrivo
[Musica]
ce l'ho fatta non svenire adesso non
svenire adesso ti prego non ce la farò
mai più legato c'è un altro ci credo non
ci credo mai proprio ruby nei take assit
siediti a dire che adesso mi devo sedere
per arrivare dalle cose ma per chi si
sposta ne va bene
bravo come se stessi cagando perfetto
zio michè ci arriverò prima o poi
perfetto torna su no no non ci credo non
ci credo non ci credo mai ragazza che ti
prende vicente adame posso arrivarci
anche così oddio non penso proprio
magari facciamo piano piano piano e sul
sì o sul no perché perché sei scemo se
in piedi bravo bravo non svenire non
svenire
bravi tutti ingobbito vai vai vai con la
gobba con la gobba bravo perfetto
perfetto rock live climber che questo
non è difficile credo è credo credo non
era difficile un livello fattibile non
ci posso credere mai vai vai vai
lukather è perfetto ma come to the limbo
che mancava il banco so cammina dritto
io lo fa limbo ma sei stupido nel
cervello
pavone senso siamo gli archi al 9 st
armero per la madonna perché sono caputo
fine cazzo dai una dizione ce l'avevo
veramente fatta non ci posso credere
ragazzi io limbo non lo so fare neanche
normalmente ci mancherebbe in un
videogame
c'è veramente vi giuro dai dai dai non
tutto si siamo se riesco a passare dai
dai dai dai
su su su su altre girati non cadere non
cade non cadere se non cade a [ __ ] vai
dritto quanto difficile quanto difficile
vai vai mai arrivare mai perfetto ci
posso credere
cos'è quella roba lì devo va bene che
ama sta scherzando ma mappe hanno appena
riesco a farlo con the fermo quanto sta
diventando difficile sto gioco
bye bye bye bye zio paesi ove zio
normale col culo normale bravo bravo
bravo girati non devi offrire il caffè
al caso della tessera vai vai vai vai
non è vero non ho dato tempo sono scemo
ma dài dài minchia già fatta ma o veloce
penso di averne 30 mai mai mai mai mai
fatta ce l'ha fatta senza morire
non ci posso credere a livello nove
ragazzi siamo quasi al 10
sono commosso cos'è sta roba cos'è sta
roba cosa devo fare come faccio a
salirci ma se non riesce a salire anche
un gradino sotto come cazzo fai a
lavorare in un ufficio o perfetto non
chiedetemi con fatto forse un bug cosa
cazzo fai vai dritto vai dritto è che
c'è solo 10 secondi pirla perfetto non
saprò mai più non sarei andata di culo
questa e non so come ho fatto palance
bim
cosa devo fare no va bene devo andare se
va bene capire certo questo è svenuto
ancora prima di arrivare alla rampa
piano piano piano piano piano piano
piano perfetto girati kireyev ai vai vai
vai vai dritto più dritto poi devo
scendere fare limbo questo devo fare
capito cosa devo fare dopo ok perfetto
ma devo scendere
no vabbè ragazzi non ce la farò mai come
faccio a fare il limbo ma io mi butto
chissenefrega jolo velocissimo lui ci
credo ho fatta pensava probabilmente
dovevo fare il giro ma mi sono salvato
non so quanti i livelli ci sono i sto
gioco spiegate me lo voglio capire amadò
ma cos'è come faccio a fare questa col
novara impossibile non ci sto neanche
sopra come faccio ok passettino
passatina passettino passettino
passettino passantino veloce quanto
storica [ __ ] levi e che l'ati davanti
che cazzo mi fa venire il nervoso quando
lo vedo che si piega non riesco più a
raddrizzarlo mia famiglia il nervoso si
piegherà il suo crea raddrizzarne avanti
avanti avanti avanti avanti avanti la tv
no non ricadono che cado un bravissimo
già fatta adesso discendere devi
scendere di odori scendere piano che ci
hai 30 secondi hai fatto prima
è un professioni cup a cura e vai vai
vai vai vai vai provate mai l'uomo con
la maglietta rosa vince ancora e andiamo
e non oso pensare come rimorchi frate
non ho idea di come lei sembra che si è
cagato nei pantaloni ce l'ha fatta
non so come ma ce l'ho fatta perfetto
define arte o finale ragazzi ci siano
the final test sarai più difficile della
storia però va beh allora calmati sono
vivo mi sono salvato come come come
salgo come salgo non salgo non si possa
lì non mi fa salire ai ragazzi c'è un
problema c'è un problema di fondo qui
bravo
ok magari piedi frate no cosa fai
qual è il problema c'hai se ne hai solo
uno è che sarebbe un complimento
ok ok ok ok ok piano piano piano ho
devin al bravissimo bravissimo girati
girati girati anche se ti sei taggato
nei pantaloni entra così e nell'ufficio
chissenefrega
bravo bravo bravo si no oddio sono fatta
così the party o mio dio sa sono io che
visto comandando aurea unghie a oria
olbia ama ama ama ama ama non mi
stupisce che adesso tuffi ct abbia
assunto se ha assunto anche sta gente
oyeah ciao zio come savica questo
simpson
cos'è è pupa misto page io sono caduto
prove la causa ragazzi io chiuderei più
addio quanto è figo quello conclude qui
anche perché il gioco credo che non
abbia un senso dato che il tipo c'è la
posizione tipo ariel che dire ragazzi
gioco dell'anno cosa sento se vi è
piaciuto a sull argomento è un mi piace
anche la passione di facebook e come
votare tiziana 67 per i sinti scattare
ci mettiamo fosse un video belle ragazze